je suis dans la galerie des Glaces
l'onde de 73 mètres devant cette table
qui va accueillir ce soir les 160
invités une table de 60 mètres avec ce
service de porcelaine de Sèvres le
service aux oiseaux chaque assiette vaut
des milliers d'euros elle est peinte à
la main tout comme la dorure c'est ici
donc le roi la reine le président de la
République et son épouse se retrouveront
ce soir pour le dîner qui sera donné en
l'honneur du roi Charles III à partir de
21h bonjour Docteur j'ai besoin d'un
avortement un avortement oui j'ai un
polichinel dans le tiroir comment vous
allez faire le tuer d'abord et l'aspirer
ensuite Monsieur Madame Garrison
[Musique]